MONOLOGUE.
2 WOMEN WHO ACCUSED PRESIDENT
BILL CLINTON OF SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT.
PAULA JONES AND JUANITA
BRODERICK.
YOU HAVE A NEW BOOK THAT CAME
OUT.
I DON'T HAVE A COPY.
>> OH, I HAVE IT.
>> Sean: HOW I SURVIVED BY BEING
RAPED BY BILL CLINTON.
EVER INTERVIEWED ON 60s?
>> NO, NEVER NOR CNN OR NBC.
>> Sean: NEVER BEEN INTERVIEWED
BY "60 MINUTES."
IT WAS HARD TO GET ON NBC WITH
LISA MYERS WHO I KNOW WANTED TO
AIR HER INTERVIEW WITH YOU?
>> YES.
>> Sean: I SAID THIS TO YOU.
IN 23 YEARS AT FOX AND 30 YEARS
IN RADIO, YOU WRITE ABOUT SOME
OF THE THIS IN THE BROOK, IT WAS
HARDEST INTERVIEW I HAVE EVER
DONE?
>> THAT'S RIGHT AND YOU WERE THE
SECOND INTERVIEW THAT I HAD DONE
AND THE LAST.
THERE WAS DOROTHY IN BETWEEN.
WHEN YOU CAME TO MY HOME WITH
ALL OF YOUR PEOPLE AND SAT DOWN,
I NEVER THOUGHT ABOUT THIS BEING
AS EMOTIONAL TO YOU AS IT WAS TO
ME.
WE SAT DOWN.
AS I TOLD YOU THE HORRIFIC
EVENTS.
>> Sean: IT WAS A BRUTAL RAPE?
>> WHEN I BEGAN TO TELL YOU
ABOUT THAT, I TURNED AND LOOKED
AT YOU AND HE HAD TEARS IN HIS
EYES.
IT JUST OVERWHELMED ME.
YOU HAVE ALWAYS BEEN SO GOOD TO
US.
I APPRECIATE IT.
>> Sean: ONE THING THAT LISA
MYERS SAID TO YOU WHEN SHE SAID
WE CAN'T AIR THE INTERVIEW RIGHT
NOW.
GOOD NEWS AND BAD NEWS.
YOU ARE CREDIBLE AND TOO
CREDIBLE.
THIS WHOLE TITLE YOU BETTER PUT
ICE ON THAT.
IT'S FROM THE STORY.
HE RAPED AND HE BIT YOUR LIP?
>> YES, HE BIT MY LIP TO KEEP MY
QUIET.
THE TIME HE WAS LEAVING THE
ROOM, CALMLY PUTS ON HIS
SUNGLASSES MOTIONS TO MY LIP,
YOU BETTER PUT SOME ICE ON THAT
AND COLDLY WALKS OUT THE DOOR.
>> Sean: YOU HAD THE EXPERIENCE.
YOU WON YOUR LAWSUIT?
>> I DID.
>> Sean: YOU GOT A JUDGMENT?
>> IF YOU ASK THE LIBERALS
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
>> Sean: YOU WON A LOT OF MONEY?
>> I DID.
>> Sean: HE EXPOSED YOURSELF IN
A HOTEL ROOM.
INVITED TO YOU A HOTEL ROOM AND
DROPPED HIS PANTS.
YOU WATCHED THE INTERVIEW WITH
STORMY DANIELS, RIGHT?
>> YES, I DID.
>> Sean: YOU SEE THE HYSTERIA OF
THE COVERAGE.
>> INSANE.
>> Sean: COMPARE
>> Sean: COMPAIN
>> Sean: COMPAING
>> Sean: COMPAING Y
>> Sean: COMPAING YOU
>> Sean: COMPAING YOUR
>> Sean: COMPAING YOUR ST
>> Sean: COMPAING YOUR STOR
>> Sean: COMPAING YOUR STORIE
>> Sean: COMPAING YOUR STORIES?
>> THERE IS NO COMPARISON.
MR. TRUMP IF HE DID THAT, IT WAS
NOT A CRIME.
HE DID NOT DO SOMETHING THAT WAS
A CRIME.
THERE IS A DIFFERENCE THERE.
SHE ADMITTED HE DIDN'T DO
ANYTHING THAT HURT HER.
SHE WAS A WILLING PARTICIPANT.
WE DIDN'T GET THE KIND OF
COVERAGE SHE IS GETTING.
>> Sean: NOT EVEN CLOSE.
>> WE WERE MADE FUN ABOUT ON
LATE NIGHT TALK SHOWS.
>> Sean: CONSTANTLY?
>> YES, I HAVE NEVER LIVED IN A
TRAILER PARK BUT THAT'S THE WAY
THEY TREATED US.
THIS IS A SERIOUS THING.
EVEN THROUGH HILLARY CLINTON'S
ELECTION, SHE NEVER EVER WAS
ASKED ANYTHING ABOUT US WOMEN.
NEVER.
>> Sean: SHE SAID WOMEN HAVE A
RIGHT TO BE HEARD?
>> YES, ABSOLUTELY.
>> Sean: AND BELIEVED.
HAVING INTERVIEWED BOTH OF YOU
AND KATHLEEN IN THE PAST, I
REMEMBER SAYING, DOES THAT MEAN
WE BELIEVE JUANITA BRODERICK
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT!
AFTER I TREATED WHAT I DID ON
JANUARY 6th, SHE CALMLY REMOVED
YOU SHOULD BE BELIEVED FROM HER
WEBSITE.
>> Sean: INTERESTING.
YOU TWEETED LAST NIGHT AT
ANDERSON COOPER AND "60
MINUTES."
WOULD YOU LIKE TO INTERVIEW ME
ABOUT MY BOOK?
>> YES.
>> Sean: YOU HAVE HEARD FROM
ANDERSON?
>> NO, BUT I AM NOT A PORN STAR.
I WAS A HARD WORKING NURSE AND A
BUSINESS WOMAN.
I WAS NOT A PORN STAR.
THAT'S WHY THEY WERE NOT
INTERESTED IN ME.
>> Sean: THE IDEA IS I ALWAYS
TALKED ABOUT THIS PRESIDENT
HAVING 5 BIG GROUPS AGAINST HIM.
THE DEEP STATE.
THE LIBERAL MEDIA AND DEMOCRATS
AND REPUBLICANS AND IF YOU ARE A
DEMOCRAT ME TOO DOESN'T MATTER.
IT SEEMS IF YOU ARE A DEMOCRAT,
WOMEN'S RIGHTS DON'T MATTER.
YOU TWO ARE EXAMPLES OF IT.
>> I KNOW.
IT'S LIKE WHEN THEY CONTACTED ME
TO DO AN INTERVIEW FOR THE ME
TOO, I TOLD THEM I DIDN'T FEEL A
PART OF THAT.
NO ONE EVER INCLUDED ME IN THAT.
THERE WAS FROM "TIME" MAGAZINE.
>> Sean: YOU WERE ME TOO LONG
BEFORE ME TOO AND YOU WERE
BRUTALIZED.
>> THEY ASKED ME TO SUBMIT A
COMMENT.
I SAID I WILL IN SUPPORT OF ME
TOO AND THEY CAME OUT AS BEING
PERSON OF THE YEAR.
I LOOKED FOR MY COMMENT AND IT
WASN'T THERE.
>> Sean: ME TOO -- WHAT DO YOU
SAY TO ALL OF THOSE PEOPLE THAT
ARE SHOWING OUT RAGE?
>> IT'S BECAUSE THEY ARE DOING
EVERYTHING TO GET DONALD TRUMP
OUT OF OFFICE.
TRY TO DRAG OUT FACTS ABOUT HIM.
>> Sean: IS IT ABOUT NOW WE WANT
EVERY DETAIL OF EVERY CONSENSUAL
>> ONLY IF IT'S THE REPUBLICANS.
>> Sean: NOT DEMOCRATS?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
IT'S NOT ABOUT THAT.
>> Sean: WAS IT HARD SEEING ALL
OF THIS?
DOES IT BRING UP MEMORIES?
>> OH, SURE.
IT NEVER GOES AWAY.
I TWEETED THAT IN 2016.
WE SAID TODAY WHEN YOU HAVE BEEN
VICTIMIZED AS HORRIFICLE AS I
WAS IT'S IN YOUR DNA.
YOU DON'T FORGET IT.
>> Sean: PAULA JONES STARTED A
COFFEE COMPANY THAT SWEARS I
WILL LOSE WEIGHT.
THIS BOOK IS ON AMAZON.COM AND
IN BOOK STORES?
>> BARNES AND NOBEL.
>> CAN I TELL THEM MY WEBSITE?